soy una pastora soy un pastor soy pastor
soy un pastor soy un pastor soy un
pastor soy un pastor
[Música]
comenzamos con una introducción Mi
nombre es Jake soy un sacerdote
episcopal soy don Pastor no confesional
pastor luterano Paul pastor de jóvenes
Polo usaba un traje y pensé que tal vez
está compensando No sé lo que usaría un
pastor un sábado Tal vez sea un traje
era pastor de Chapel y ahora de verdad
sí soy de calvary
sí de ahí los tatuajes creo que mi
estrategia será
tratar de escuchar la razón detrás de
Por qué la gente es pastor Daniel pastor
de jóvenes no confesional soy Ana no
confesional pero he cambiado mucho con
los años Tengo una pregunta en la
educación Sí sí seminario Tal vez un
título seminario estudios teológicos
[Risas]
hago una maestría en el Western
seminario Yo estudié en el que habitable
y luego hice el programa veritas
teología con un enfoque en estudios
bíblicos iglesia no es una institución
formal pero crecía en una zona rural no
había casi nada era como un tipo de
voluntariado soy de un pueblo pequeño
con pueblos más pequeños a su alrededor
Cuando yo estudiaba todos éramos de una
misma iglesia luterana Qué tipo de
iglesia luterana como dije éramos de
varios pueblitos la luteranos
luteranos de vida
de inmediato pensé si es una pastora
luterana seguro que dirá que
denominación pertenece este pueblo
en el alto Michigan es una zona aislada
cerca de market es un pueblo grande pero
entiendo no lo es alguien lo conocería
Ana hablaba en términos muy generales ni
siquiera dijo la ciudad de la que venía
pero sí sabía el nombre de la ciudad
cercana eso es suficiente mencionaste
que no creciste en la iglesia alguien
claro
toda mi vida Me bautizaron a los siete
años creo que no me hice creyente hasta
los 30 lo hice porque me educaron es lo
que se supone que debes hacer hacer lo
que ellos hacen lo que dicen y bla bla
bla bla bla bla Sí y luego me echaron
[Risas]
por lo que sé de la iglesia luterana
debería tener una respuesta concreta y
eso me alertó
para mí es Ana listo
porque las mujeres no pueden ser
pastores
basta tienen prejuicios Adiós
ser la única mujer fue complicado al no
poder abrirme paso en la conversación no
pude presentarla de la forma que me
hubiera gustado incluso hubiera sido
mucho más eficaz llegué y me alegré de
que hubiera una pastora porque son tan
poco comunes dentro de la religión como
los pastores gay como yo todavía es un
muy nuevo ver pastores y líderes de
culto y cristianos homosexuales y
mujeres dime por qué te echaron sí Me
echaron porque a medida que fui
creciendo empecé a hacer preguntas
muchas preguntas que para mí era muy
obvias cuál era una de esas preguntas es
el bautismo esencial para la salvación
la comunión estas preguntas polémicas
que a menudo separan a las religiones y
a las creencias he sido un pastor de la
secundaria durante años y nunca
preguntaron eso quiero saber cuáles son
sus deberes a través de qué están
enseñando soy un pastor asistente de
enseñanza estamos replantando
revitalizando la iglesia sirvo en una
iglesia coreana en la mirada California
y soy pastor de jóvenes estoy semi
retirado tampoco tengo una congregación
Aunque trabajo con una es una iglesia
episcopal en San Clemente también tengo
un trabajo en el que soy capellán de una
agencia gubernamental Jake respondió a
la pregunta sobre estar retirado pero
nunca indicó de qué estaba retirado y
después de años de estar en la iglesia
pensé que tendría un cierre de sus
experiencias pero resulta que no habla
de eso dice que es asistente a tiempo
parcial pensé tenemos algunos factores
desconocidos sobre Dj no soy pastor de
una iglesia soy pastor de pastores
trabajo en una confesión y predicó en
diferentes congregaciones cada semana yo
no estoy dando discursos pero estoy
enseñando en un grupo de conversación
hay muchas polémicas dogmáticas que se
generalizan para el cristianismo tengo
una pregunta Cuándo fue la última vez
que estuviste en el hospital con alguien
y Qué consuelo le diste en ese momento
crítico
odio esa pregunta para alguien que está
en el Ministerio esto es más que
predicar y enseñar sentí que una
pregunta sobre cómo le dan el consuelo
de la presencia de Dios indicaría si
eran o no un pastor si están
involucrados en la iglesia era lo que
quería saber la última vez que estuvo en
el hospital fue hace poco me había
convertido en el apoderado médico de la
madre de un amigo
ella era anciana y fue difícil para mí
pero el consuelo que le di fue que
supiera que su familia estaba cerca y
que cuando saliera del tiempo hacia la
eternidad estaría en el lugar que
anhelaba tuve que hacerlo una vez y fue
muy reciente lo odié con cada fibra de
mi ser porque era para alguien que amaba
y mucho
había que esperar y callar y rezar en
silencio y solo estar allí y estoy
temblando lo odié
lo que me pareció ver es que se
esforzaba mucho
la forma en que estaba respondiendo a
las preguntas era muy anticuada
[Aplausos]
conocen a Jesús
ya veo lo que pasa primero la mujer
luego el hombre negro y ahora El gay ya
entiendo que pasa
Yo yo cuestiono a todos los que quedan
conocen a Jesús yo sí lo conozco si
creen que el impostor sigue aquí y
quieren seguir jugando levanten la mano
empezaremos con Qué significa el ateísmo
para ustedes hablo mucho sobre la
agnosticismo más que sobre el ateísmo
cambio la idea de no creo en Dios en Qué
es Dios Como dijo Agustín de hipona
todos los corazones están Inquietos
hasta que encuentran descanso en Dios y
el ateo no es el enemigo si no crees en
el Dios que amo y sirvo no significa que
eres el enemigo significa que estás
inquieto y tratas de Buscar sentido en
cualquier cosa que no sea Dios Tengo la
curiosidad por saber si alguien de
ustedes Tuvo una época comience usted y
tú estás muy callado Cuál era la
pregunta eres el mejor vestido sí La
pregunta era he luchado con mi fe de
hecho luché más con el llamado que con
mi fe una vez que tuve una experiencia
con Dios fuera de la adicción
mi fe era muy sólida pero con el llamado
creo que luché innumerables peces en la
secundaria mis padres decidieron
separarse Fue entonces cuando tuve
adicción a las drogas probé la
metanfetamina de cristal el primer año
eso fue
lo que me llevó al fondo al lugar más
oscuro de mi vida y la única manera de
salir es mirar hacia arriba tengo una
pregunta qué opinamos de la escatología
somos
en el fin de los tiempos estamos en el
momento en que Jesús dijo que
terminación al tema que antes como crecí
en calvary Chapel estaba hiper de
sensibilizado sí esto es soy como es un
tema sensible por el sensacionalismo y
por el origen Sí sí está bien
Oigan No creo que el final de los
tiempos sea pronto bien
Tal vez percibí un poco de malestar en
él y me pregunté si eso era parte de lo
que estaba usando como máscara por eso
percibí un poco de malestar
no les mentiré Jay me resulta familiar
puesto que es un actor que he visto
antes
hay un empate
hay un empate entre Jay
y Daniel
les daremos a cada uno 30 segundos para
exponer su caso
no sé qué decir salvo que creo que debí
No debí haber votado para seguir aparte
de eso
fui al seminario del 85 al 88
sacerdote episcopal de 35 años pensé que
pasaría porque soy muy liberal Y ustedes
lo notaron Eso es todo
Así que decir soy un pastor no me
expulsen es tan simple como eso Sé que
he sido pastor por un tiempo y estoy en
esta nueva congregación y estoy
emocionado y la razón por la que vine
fue por el dinero Quiero llevar a los
niños a un viaje Quiero ganar para los
niños Por eso estoy aquí y no quiero que
me expulsen y no sean homofóbicos en
junio
[Risas]
yo era un pastor de jóvenes teníamos
presupuesto para eso no usé mi dinero
personal vi el corazón en Jay y sentí
que Daniel era más una presentación
[Música]
lo sabía lo sabía si las luces se
vuelven verde significa que el impostor
está fuera y que ganan si las luces se
vuelven rojas significa que siguen la
caja y pierden 3 2 1
bien buen trabajo chicos bien
pueden los impostores rebelarse por
favor
3 2 1
vaya vaya
pero rezaré contra todos ustedes
verdad
Y todo lo que dijiste eso era real si
tengo un título en teología de La Biblia
de calvary una gran parte fue un deseo
personal de conocimiento y comprensión
de mi propia existencia eso fue lo que
me impulsó y quería sentir que estaba
haciendo todo lo posible para obtener
respuestas he trabajado en la iglesia
durante unos ocho años como pianista y
organista tenía mucho de Dónde sacar eso
me llamó la atención como luteranos no
hay luteranos genéricos es verdad de
verdad soy de una zona poco poblada eso
es verdad Hay pocas cosas que reúnen a
la gente hay muchas Iglesias hay
personas que son católicas otras
luteranas todo el pueblo se reunía en
una estación de servicio o en una tienda
o en sus casas
estamos en un punto de inflexión en la
comunidad cuando se trata de individuos
gay en el cristianismo aunque no soy
cristiano es estupendo ver que una parte
de esta comunidad que tiene un historial
tan amplio de negatividad contra la
nuestra Abra los ojos admitan sus
errores se Disculpen y busquen la
reconciliación y creo que puede mejorar
mientras sigan caminando por ese camino
los pastores piensan un poco más
profundo en las personas y en la
condición de su alma Espero que quienes
vean esto busquen también ese tipo de
dirección espiritual de verdad espero
que así sea
celebre sí
muy bien muy bien estoy orgulloso
[Aplausos]
[Risas]